[Musique]
la rentrée des classes autres événements
de l'automne donne beaucoup moins de
soucis aux enfants et à la maman aux
prises avec le budget familial
avec un budget moyen de 218 euros 53 en
2020 les fournitures scolaires c'est un
budget et si elle était gratuite cette
revendication est ancienne déjà porté en
1973 l'union des femmes françaises
lançait une pétition auprès de mère de
famille très réceptive en parle un peu
vulgairement mais c'est comme ça qu'elle
me dise oui moi je veux bien signer même
des deux mains pour la gratuité scolaire
parce que je n'y arrive pas et je n'y
arriverai pas pas acheter le nécessaire
pour les enfants
depuis des années 70 le marketing sans
même les cahiers et classeurs rivalisent
de couleurs et de motifs ce qui fait
grimper la note
mais dans certaines communes pas un
franc a déboursé à evry en 1995 un kit
rentrée est remis à chaque élève de
primaire financé par la mairie
pour les cm1 vous avez à placer
les feuilles les intercalaires ça y est
ext c'était quelques crayons aux
senteurs berger pour les familles entre
80 et 100 francs peu près même gratuite
et au collège de saint pantaléon en
1997 classé en zone prioritaire
d'éducation mais à certaines conditions
il n'est absolument pas question ni de
critères sociaux ni de critère de
réussite aux colères simplement
d'assiduité de nommer conclusion cette
décision c'est un choix pour les mairies
qui en ont le budget et la volonté
plutôt que je sais pas moi des feux
d'artifice par exemple qui coûte
énormément cher ou peut-être des
indemnités de fonction à rallonge où je
ne sais
quarante cinq mille francs c'est pas
énorme là où les mairies ne met pas la
main au porte monnaie il faut se
débrouiller comme dans ce collège de
courville sur eure en
1999 donc on lâche préféré acheter les
et les fournitures en gros de manière à
ce que ce soit moins cher pour les
parents la gratuité reste pour autant
loin d'être la norme est certain la
réclame toujours à metz en 2014 un
collectif s'est créé pour appeler la
mairie à financer les achats de début
d'année le stim que si l'école est
gratuite comme c'est écrit depuis la
promulgation de l'école laïque
obligatoire depuis jules ferry il n'y a
pas de raison que les parents d'élèves m
la main à la poche pour que leurs
enfants puissent aller à l'école la
gratuité des fournitures scolaires des
prises en charge qu'à l'échelle locale
au niveau national elle n'est pas
envisagée reste l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire pour les parents aux revenus
les plus bas entre 370 et 404 euros par
enfant
[Musique]